oh, no
oh boy, oh boy
Today is exciting
So we are super into those little tiny mini foods well I  bought these a while ago on Amazon and these...
Literally This is not English. Are they still so good? It's fine
Let's go through these and see which ones we want to make we've got little teeny tiny sushi like look at this little sushi
Actual sushi no. no it's not actual sushi. It's like Candy gummy sushi. Okay, just checking
little donuts, oh lets do this one
I really want to do this one though
look at this little tiny ice cream cones okay cancel everything put the ice cream come on
Look at this this little teeny tiny ice cream cones. I think we should do this one. What's that?
I don't even know it's like a little bento box
We've got a lot of options so let us know what you guys would like us to do next
Because I don't know if this is gonna take a long time like what do we do these instructions?
I can't umm this is not my language, so I'm not sure but let's do this one, okay
Let's start with the ice cream and see what happens
There's pictures. We just gotta figure it out. I guess it doesn't look like there's much in here ready for this oh
Yeah, let's open it up, okay
This is not gonna go well I can't even figure out how to open the box. Oh
Look at this. Very lovely, scissors. We understand that picture. That's it right here what? oh. Look how cute.
This is Super cute look at it. Teeny tiny cones.
oh, oh
Gotta cut this out. why? I think that's supposed to be like a little plate. We can do without the plate. Yeah!
It shows these little things you're supposed to cut out
You can't eat it so like what we actually do with it both Edibles on things we could eat
I like the way this- okay what's it say my box. It's not my language
Oh, I mean one of the first picture look like you get the cone out
Okay, we got the cone cone in the little wafer I
feel like a giant
Look, but it's it's telling us to put water in here
Let's use a translator. Oh wait wait wait. What we cut off this corner? Oh
We don't need a translator. We'll figure this out with our brain. Yes
I'm still gonna download the translate, you should because it's all i can understand. Look at this
Look at this stuff. Isn't it neat. make two of these oh
oh cause it's translating to Spanish
It's doing instant translation
Help picture hold on don't move yeah, this isn't going well
Okay, we'll just use our brain
Honestly, this is what we do fill that up with water
Oh, touched my butt, didn't mean to you touched my butt, okay so put that in, you sure
Yeah, you sure no put it in here
Yep, don't yell at me now can I get another water yes get another water, so no we mix this up real good
excuse, stick it in
Okay, nice loving goo it smells nice
Does it not get cold or? It's like fake ice cream, mix with this. This is all mixed up real nice. all mixed
What to do dad you turn around a minute Anna wait was just to break up the wafers a little yeah
That's like a step last can you hold that?
Yes, if we can get the whole scoop
In what I put it on the other side pays nice case very nice really let's just stick that in there
Okay, yeah place it up
Oh, God, they flip boo. It's a little gooey to be fair
I'm gonna die potentially oh, no. I'm gonna Die I've been in a box for
Probably years really really just eating chemicals
I don't think that's the problem is this all we have to do is this the entire thing. Yes, it's boring
No
I'm having a swell time except I'm probably gonna drop at the end of this video now
Would you like you have a mini plate? I?
Do I know but I don't know him. I don't know where it is either. There's a mini plate somewhere. We just want to
couple
Okay, so now we've got our little teeny tiny plates and everything looks great. So we're gonna. Do you want to break those down?
Oh, I'll fill up one of our combs. Well. Where's the pink the pink is not coming out yet?
It looks so silly you're gonna open up our I had made a teeny tiny message teeny tiny bit
I can't believe this is an entire video. You've done work. That's true
What I did the teeny tiny Sprinkles will you put them all over there, so yeah, this is wrinkled bum. Oh yes. Oh you wait
What's great Sprinkles art staying on the go? It's super sticky. It's so small
That's cool
Okay, we can satin or look okay super stack. We have to taste it after I've just did
Oh, why'd I do that? I thought it was a
Conceptual icing like it. Just really is a very beautiful work of art
It tastes like if you've accidentally thing licked a hot tire that's off
How would you even I don't know I just imagine like rubber like I take some melted rubber. It's super cute
It's so cute. Look it up. Oh wow me the same nails
You do dips this cancer is
There okay. We try it. I don't know let's just take a little bite, okay
Oh gah, big mouthful of dough, huh, it's not good at all
Okay, so I don't I do not like it
It's a drink
Help me
That's it. I'm not even gonna try this because this was so gross, but I will say wait is this is this edible what?
Wait a minute. It's not edible. I have no idea poppin cookin it
Just opens it says okay, but those orbeez also said something, and I can't read this so I actually have no idea
I would assume. This is edible. Did I just eat and go I did what yeah, hop and cook and edible? Oh my God?
What did you do to me? Yes, okay? It is Diy candy kids our edible
Have I made of edible candy powder, okay perfect it was actually slightly concerned because I was looking at this and I
Thought this doesn't look like something. I mean it does look Edible, but it did not I did no, I don't think that tasted
Well, thanks for watching thanks to Jennifer hanging out in my kitchen making a little teeny tiny ice cream come let us know if you?
Would like us to make any more of these because I've got a lot of them. I vote for Doughnuts, please
We can make a thanksgiving meal of tiny meals
I'm into it. Okay. I'm done. Thanks for watching guys. We'll see you soon
I got a two year all wish to do with us. I'm gonna put it back in its box
Let's deposit this into the trash your obedient little disgust